- We're back.
Babin, we back?
- I'll see you back.
- We're back.
(hip-hop beat)
(hip-hop music)
Big shout out to everybody.
Here with AJ Vee.
(AJ talking on phone)
Going to a super,
secret VaynerSports meeting.
Obviously if you've been paying
any attention to my social.
VaynerSports, hot time this season.
Building out our draft class,
getting very excited about it.
All the business development with brands.
So we're headed to this meeting.
Super excited, had a great holiday.
Hope you guys are well aware
of my Eric Decker t-shirt.
He's on the Titans now but what he did
yesterday in the playoff game,
everybody was shitting on him.
He was down, he had a big
drop and then he came back
with the perseverance,
had the big touchdown to win the game.
Big shout out E.D.
You know I don't like
anybody but the Jets.
But former Jets still
hold a piece of my heart.
Anyway, big meeting.
Excited to be here in LA.
CES this week, back on the grind.
Great family time,
great to be checked out.
Great to be spending time with AJ.
Great to be spending time
with a lot of you brands.
Making these biz dev
deals with VaynerSports.
This will be a fun episode.
And I'm ready to go.
(hip-hop music)
Had a great break.
Had a lot of time to think about 2018.
Feel very focused.
Nothing too crazy.
Just good solid grinding and
focus on the VaynerX world and
obviously, K-Swiss, my book,
those kind of things but
it's just gonna be a,
it's gonna be a putting your head down,
bring your lunch pale to work,
grinding 15 hours a day kinda thing
and just focused as fuck.
Like really fuckin' focused Babin.
- Was it good?
- It was actually good.
Not gonna lie.
- Bro.
- [AJ] Yeah?
- [Gary] It's just a lot to
handle 'cause it's so exciting.
It's just so real.
- [AJ] Yup
- [Gary] Think about what I talk about.
Positivity and Mogul life.
Like it's so good.
- [AJ] And legitimate.
It's not like some
fraudster running around.
- Actually let me give you
the meat of this episode
'cause I know a lot of it's
not gonna be able to be seen.
I've come to realize and
it's happening right now
with VaynerSports,
obviously it's super fun
to do a second go around
with my favorite man,
AJ Vee over here.
There's just nothing like the beginning
of building a fucking monster.
(chuckling)
There's nothing like it.
- Build.
- I love the underestimated, I love the,
every single thing I've done, people tell,
actually the second and
third big thing I did.
Why VaynerMedia and why VaynerSports.
There's an article on VaynerSports.
There's an article on VaynerMedia.
If you dig on the web enough, it says,
"He doesn't know what he's
getting into. This is different."
Let me just promise all
you fuck faces forever,
none of it's gonna be different.
Whatever fuckin' industry I
choose, they're in trouble
if we decide to actually do it.
There's gonna be a lot that I flirt with
that I'm gonna talk a little big game
but I'll never go deep.
But if we go deep, it's a fuckin' wrap.
Curtains on the industry and I just,
this is the most fun.
Like I love the hard
part, I love the X work,
I love getting on the
phone with a bunch of you
that are filling out the
Google form for biz dev
and negotiating, if you
wanna give 15 thousand,
I wanna get it to 25 and like,
you know like, the
commission on that's $1500
and it's so not worth my 15 minutes.
But it's like trading a baseball card,
it's the game, the journey, the ride,
doing it with somebody
you respect and love
always makes it so much better.
But to be very frank, like I'm
sure it's the same for you,
even without that part, I
think I like the part of
the unknown, knowing it's gonna happen
but you never know until you know.
The descending voices motivate me.
You know, I don't know if it's a flaw,
I don't know if it's strength
but I definitely love it,
and then the moments.
- Yeah.
- Like all of you on Twitter, going crazy
when you see in the green room
at the NFL Draft, you know?
That's just funny, like Gary Vee.
And I then I go on like Live and I'm like,
"Ahh, I don't know if
I'm allowed to do this."
I get banned, like I'm crazy
like that. I like that shit.
Anyway,
if you don't have the high
that I have right now,
see this is a key moment.
This is why, that's all fun
and I give you some context
but here's the real punchline.
If you don't love it, for the loving it,
and it's about the money, you've lost.
- Yeah, the highs have to be high.
Period.
- Like you know?
Like, like, none of this is
smart for me financially.
- Not for me either.
- It's just not.
But,
it's just the game man.
And you know what else?
Providing value.
Like, what was really
interesting with WineLibrary,
VaynerMedia and now VaynerSports,
is I know that I'm making
the customer happier.
It's like that Amazon effect, right?
Jeff, I'm sure, knew he
was gonna build a monster
but he also knew he was making
it better for the customer.
Like I changed the premium
price points of wine in America.
Like they all came down.
Like, we put pressure on people
doing better digital marketing
if they didn't want to
lose their business.
And now in sports, we're
gonna force agencies
to do a lot more for
their athletes because
when they can point to VaynerSports,
they're gonna be like,
- Yup.
It's not where it was,
it's where it's going
and it's changing.
- Everybody's trading on the past.
- Yup.
And they don't wanna let go either.
- Why?
You're winning.
- They're gonna have to.
- Love this part.
Best part is I'm documenting this time.
Wish I had this the last two times.
- Imagine VaynerMedia's early days.
- Imagine our ghetto ass
piece of shit first office
in Buddy Media's conference
room, our sun shined suites
and we're just like, "We're gonna do it."
- Yup.
- You guys don't know.
Our bathroom at VaynerMedia's
better than our first office.
- That's true.
(laughing)
Bigger and cleaner.
- So in wrapping it up, you gotta love it.
And most of you don't.
You're trying to figure out the money,
you're chasing the most current thing.
Do you love cryptocurrency or
do you think it's a goldmine?
And that's great, I mean if
you're about it but like,
to really go all time.
Not to become rich.
Do you like love it or do you think like,
you gotta love it.
It's so much better.
It's such a better way.
Not that crypto, cryptocurrency's
gonna win but like,
you know like, it's so
much better to love it.
- And some people love cryptocurrency.
- Yeah love it.
They love math, they love it.
You know like I get it.
I get it.
100%.
- Just thinking about putting
pressure on industries.
- 100%.
Just love it though.
Love it for like, love it
like you can't wait to wake up
and do it.
It's so fuckin' cliche but
because I'm in the moment
right this second and
you guys have seen it
on my social over the last seven days,
when I'm hot like that, I've
talked about VaynerSports
more in the last seven days
on social I did 'em first.
I'm also a funny guy that way.
I don't, you know like--
- You wanna get to a certain point.
- Yeah, you know how you have a kid
and you're like that not
that into it the first year
because it's cute but like,
but then it gets really
good, you know like,
I'm a little bit like that
with the first year of a company too.
I'm also like a shark.
Oh wait a minute, is that a
drop of blood in the water?
I can see it and now
everybody's in trouble.
Like at first you know--
- You need context, figuring it out.
- Now there's fuckin' blood.
Now there's fuckin' blood baby.
I feel bad.
I feel fucking bad.
Can't wait to recall this
fuckin' clip in four years.
It's game time.
This is where Babin stops filming.
Well, you could film a little bit.
So look, I'm on?
- Yeah.
- So look, it was unbelievable.
Like we couldn't share
anything with you but, Babin,
actually I'm gonna interview you.
Like, the talk you just heard.
Like what's running through your mind?
You know it's funny, even my own brother,
they're not in a room
with me a lot these days.
- Yeah.
What are you taking away
from the way we postgamed
off this big meeting?
- Pretty unbelievable.
Just seeing how quickly
you put in place just,
for VaynerSports to be the
most insane thing in the world.
- And if it doesn't happen
tonight, I like it even,
you guys don't understand.
You do not understand.
If I lose tonight, it's even better.
How do you fuckin' beat
somebody like that?
How do you beat somebody like me?
You don't.
I created framework that
doesn't let you beat me.
If I win, I win and if I lose, I win.
Actually you're filming right now right?
- Yeah it's still recording.
- Let's please, please,
- Thank you brother.
- Nice to meet you man.
- Nice to meet you.
Yes sir.
- So crazy.
- Nice to meet you man, what's your name?
- Herman.
- Herman, thanks for saying wassup man.
- Nice to meet you man.
- I was just like,
- You were just driving?
And just jumped out?
- Yeah.
- I love the hustle man.
Do your thing, good luck.
- Thank you.
- Thanks for saying wassup.
How do you beat this?
Justin.
For the vlog.
That pizza dude knows who I am.
(chuckling)
For the vlog.
- Yeah.
- This was the first
time you really saw me
in an environment like that.
What do you have to say
to the Vayner Nation
about what you saw?
Don't stroke it.
Just like shoot it straight
as if I wasn't here.
Which I know isn't possible but still try.
- It was like a whirlwind, literally.
Like you were in a vortex.
We talked about it.
It was the Gary Show.
It was full Gary Show.
And it was like time lapsed.
When we left the meeting,
people were like,
"Shit, that was like a
movie I was just in."
And it was wild.
Win, lose or draw, it was bomb as hell.
- Now I weirdly wanna lose
'cause I wanna be able
to recall this moment and just be like,
'cause that's the game.
If you don't love, if
you do not love losing,
you fuckin' lost.
By the way, loving
losing is hating to lose.
Let me clarify this 'cause
everyone's confused by this.
Loving to love is hating to lose
but respecting the game you play
and understanding that's
part of the fuckin' equation.
You're doing things differently.
And so it's like, you know?
I'm empathetic, and
what makes me palpable,
is I get it.
Like I understand, but I
knew what had to be done.
Listen, what do you think I'm good at?
Why do you think this is
such a good business for me?
This is the people business.
- Exactly.
- You know who's the
all time people person?
Me, period.
That's what I will go down as.
I like people, I'm a good guy.
- It's the people business.
- I'm a fuckin', I'm the biggest shark
and the biggest fuckin'
like good guy, period.
And that's facts.
- That's not wrong.
It's a people business.
- You understand?
- Yeah.
- People don't believe that
I'm this nice of a guy.
You know what I mean?
People don't know who I am.
Babin, nobody knows you better than me.
Even better in a weird way than like,
I'm so much better of a
guy than anybody could,
even my biggest fan thinks, right?
'Cause he sees the secrets.
He sees the way I fire people,
how I take care of people,
what I do.
- [Babin] That, the like firing someone,
and then doing everything
you can to help that person
was the biggest unlock for me.
Like the way I saw you
treat a handful of people.
- Or the way I treat The
Rock versus The Schmock.
("Ballin" by 3VM)
- [Gary] Everybody's
got different journeys.
Kurt Warner's going in the Hall of Fame.
The guy was bagging fuckin' groceries.
That piece of shit in New
England who I hate more than life
went in the sixth fuckin' round.
New England's not special, they got lucky.
That's luck.
Like don't tell me, if you knew something,
you woulda taken him a lot earlier.
- [Man] Taken in the sixth round.
- [Gary] You know?
Just never know.
Kurt Warner would've never had his career
if Trent Green didn't get
hurt in the preseason.
Just woulda never happened.
There's just too much.
That was tremendous.
Just like an early moment,
getting four of our
guys together for dinner
who happen to be out here training.
Just enjoyed it, been an incredible day.
VaynerSports is off and rockin'.
This is the VaynerSports episode.
I've said my piece.
I wish these videos
existed for VaynerMedia.
I wish even more they
existed for WineLibrary.
But here's the good part Babin.
They exist for VaynerSports.
Actually.
(hip-hop music)